the Joe Rogan experience yeah it's
always hard when someone does side on
the woke like what do you are you doing
this because you think this or are you
doing this because you think it'll make
people think more highly of you if you
do it it's such a contrived thing today
it's so difficult to figure out why
people are acting the way they're acting
so when they were acting in that way it
was so transparent it was there was no
if ands or buts about it like they were
pressured and they were worried about
the money they were worried about
economic you know yeah whatever fallout
yeah whatever fall would happen right it
was really obvious it was like whoa this
is not like trans people using the
bathroom this is like you guys are
threatened right exactly yeah but the
number of companies that have count out
to China's you know orthodoxy is there
should be a list somebody should be
keeping track of all of this they're
companies like Marriott even like luxury
brands so I think Versace or Dolce &
Gabbana got in trouble because I think
on the website they list it like
countries that were in and it was like
they put Hong Kong Macau and Taiwan and
China said no no no wait what are you
doing this is all China right if you
don't change that website you're not
going to be allowed to do business and
everyone wants a share of the Chinese
market that's the problem it's like the
biggest market in the world not maybe
India is bigger but well at least in the
future India will get bigger but
everyone wants access to Chinese market
so so they're able to use that as
leverage to basically bully companies
even movie execs to produce the content
they want so several I think World War Z
was affected you know the other movie
was Doctor Strange the Marvel movie
where the character played by Tilda
Swinton was supposed to be a team and
monk but you can't like Tibet is this
like hot-button issue for China right
like people have been fighting for
independence for a while the Dalai Lama
was exiled so they changed the character
it wasn't a Tibetan monk it was this
they change it to a Celtic monk and they
made it to be a woman playing the
character instead to appease the Chinese
government so they they changed it in
the American version as well yeah so
that woman well American version is
right because the studio's they're all
going in on these deals are China
China's financing all these movies now
Wow so that woman in dr. strange was
initially supposed to be a Tibetan monk
Wow yeah but they check they rewrote it
to reflect the celtic celtic female monk
yeah whoa and I think that recent the
the Top Gun movie that's coming out with
Tom Cruise - partially financed by China
and they have these like his jacket
people noticed that there was a patch
that was like missing and it turns out
like that patch it was like a for some
reason China was just triggered by it
and it was gone just in the costume this
is it yes what was the problem
it was Japanese fire that's the
Taiwanese flag yeah the USS Galveston
see it
Wow but but that's what that's what
makes it so scary that they're able to
pressure people to change their behavior
from afar without no bullets this is
just money money access so many [ __ ]
that's why I think like one of the
solutions to this is to really like
start I know somebody should really
start a website maybe me me own to just
track all this stuff all the companies
that have kept our Kyle talented China
all the ones we're standing the ground
you know and so you can decide where to
put your money so it's just a giant part
of the market that's the problem with
these films it's like it's probably the
top gun over in China first of all China
invests and then they sell those movies
over there and they're it's an enormous
part of their overall budget right what
largest the in terms of the box office
the outside of the United States the
second largest market is China the third
one is Japan and it's it's a crazy
one-fifth of China basically so it's not
nowhere it nowhere close and you know
we're all driven by profits it's
capitalism I think they try to get Quint
you know to change his movie for China I
told him to go pound saying I think so I
remember yeah the new one yeah well yeah
it's uh it's weird that it's not easy
just just throw some money around and
people change their culture right I mean
Google was developing a search engine
for China you know there well I knew
some people at Google while that was
going on and there their position was if
we don't do this they're gonna copy our
search engine and just steal all the
intellectual property or we can work
with them and provide a censored version
of Google and I remember sitting there
going this is almost like legalizing
drugs like it's messy there's no good
way here this is their bolt they both
suck like well it sucks if they steal
you know the intellectual copyright if
they they steal the ideas and create
their own version of Google it also
sucks if Google goes over there and self
censors right and provides them with you
know the ability to filter out
information but I think also that if
there's also an argument that if it was
Google at least maybe they have one
tentacle in China and so therefore it
might be able to change things or keep a
pulse and you know have their pulse on
something there's the argument well this
they blocked huawei or I shouldn't say
at least but it's interesting that they
blocked Huawei from using all their apps
so Huawei no longer has apps they didn't
have no longer have access to the Google
Play Store so they're their new phones
they have to have their own apps yes
this is with the the mate I think it's
p40 this is what it's called their
newest latest flagship phone they can't
they don't have access anymore
there's some some apps you can side load
from the web and you can download them
directly to your phone but for the most
part their access to the Google Play
Store is completely shut off so the
thousands and thousands of apps that
feel like if you want if you were a lot
of people apps or everything it's not
the film itself with the apps if you
don't have Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook and
whatever the you know equivalents are in
different countries you kind of [ __ ] out
of luck
I think reciprocity is a good policy to
abide by right so like if China can
influence us if you want because the
Chinese they always use the their market
as you look will shut you out of our
market if you don't do this well we
should be doing the same right which i
think is what Trump had tried to do with
the tariffs we're gonna shut you out of
a market we're going to penalize you you
know unless you open up some things
you've been you know there have been
unfair trade practices for a while
[Applause]